Un des airtoute les plus
populaires au monde.
- Le point de départ pour
découvrir le travail de Yayoi
Kusama, c'est justement le point
ou les pois, comme l'indique
la commissaire de l'exposition
Cheryl Sim.
CHERYL SIM, directrice générale
commissaire à la PHI
- Le point ou les pois,
c'est vraiment sa marque.
L'idée pour elle, c'est
qu'on est tous de petits points
dans l'univers et d'explorer
cette question de l'univers qui
est énorme, le cosmos qui n'a
pas de fin. Comment est-ce qu'on
peut se retrouver là-dedans?
Ça fait remonter des questions
très existentielles.
- Yayoi Kusama est née en 1929
au Japon. Elle débarque aux
États-Unis à la fin des années
50, où elle côtoie de grands
noms de l'art contemporain comme
Georgia O'Keeffe, Donald Judd
ou Andy Warhol.
- Très rapidement, je dirais
59, 60, elle a commencé vraiment
à avoir une critique favorable
qui a propulsé une carrière
internationale.
- Prolifique, l'artiste
japonaise Yayoi Kusama a touché
au cours de sa longue carrière
plusieurs formes d'art :
peinture, sculpture,
performance, mais pour le grand
public, ses salles de miroirs
infinis sont probablement
ses oeuvus connues.
La fondation PHI en présente
deux dans cette exposition
gratuite.
- C'est une expérience qui est
calmante, qui amène une certaine
tranquillité, un réconfort,
qui est important et intéressant
quand on pense au travail de
Kusama, parce qu'elle a aussi
vécu des troubles de santé
mentale, des hallucinations,
l'angoisse et elle se sert
de son travail pour canaliser
ses angoisses, ses peurs,
ses questions.
- En effet, depuis la fin
des années 70, l'artiste,
aujourd'hui âgée
habite dans un hôpital
psychiatrique au Japon,
ce qui ne l'empêche pas d'aller
régulièrement à son atelier
et de continuer à créer
et à nous faire réfléchir
sur notre monde.
Et son travail plaît
et attire les foules.
- C'est assez euphorisant,
poétique, déstabilisant, oui,
définitivement, donc c'est
vraiment merveilleux.
- Chaque oeuvre d'art se
complète d'une pièce à l'autre
et ça, ça fait, juste, bien
compléter le tout.
- L'exposition est présentée
jusqu'au mois de janvier, à
la fondation PHI mais à cause
de la demande, il faut réserver
ses billets d'avance. Le 15
chaque mois, de nouveaux billets
sont mis en vente.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Mon